2997. that's how many people have been
killed in Chicago since 2019 the Year
Laurie Lightfoot took office as mayor
fifteen thousand four hundred thirty six
that is how many people have been shot
in Chicago
since the year Lori Lightfoot took
office
it's an American city
those numbers
seem pretty high don't they but to
understand just how high consider New
York and La New York and LA are also
both high crime cities especially La
these days and yet last year Chicago's
homicide rate was two and a half times
higher than LA's
it was five times higher than New York's
Chicago's murder rate had been going
down in 2016 2017 2018 then Lori
Lightfoot took over
in 2019 and it spiked
Chicago in The Lightfoot era has been a
war zone
none of that is particularly surprising
to people who pay attention to the news
what is surprising what is delightfully
surprising is that Chicago residents are
finally doing something about it because
last night Lori Lightfoot lost her
re-election bid for Chicago mayor
she didn't even make the top two which
means that Paul vallis and Brandon
Johnson will head to the April 4th
runoff in the race Lori Lightfoot will
ride off into the sunset all of this
should give at least some hope to
dejected conservatives who think that
there is no hope for the country if even
Screwed Up Chicago can muster the
political vision and will to throw a bum
out what's stopping the rest of us from
doing the same thing at the national
level I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show before we begin
make sure you smash that like And
subscribe button make sure you leave a
little comment over here
you know YouTube sometimes trying to
keep us down we want to make sure that
everybody gets to see some real news as
opposed to all that fake news that they
usually see my favorite comment
yesterday's from Jaden jehu who says I
don't know how you haven't been banned
yet Big Mike but I'm here for it keep
preaching the truth brother some people
have noticed that I've had a lot of
bleeps and things added into my show big
Tech sensor bars because of the big Tech
rules that tell me that I can't say
certain things but you know me if you
tell me that I can't say something that
is true and just then I have to say it
and I have to say we're going to make
very very clear what big Tech is
censoring on this show and if you want
the uncensored chair you go to
dailywire.com Knowles you put in code
nulls you'll save a lot of money you'll
get a daily wire membership but we are
not going to just cut out portions of
this show or my commentary not going to
happen okay
we are feeling good we're feeling
energized we're feeling confident I
think we're all looking good very well
as well and when you want to look good
you got to check out genucel right now
go to geniusell.com Knowles do you want
to look as young and sexy and Youthful
and vibrant as I do well then you got to
check out geniusell people are raving
about genu cell skincare Jessica from
Huntsville Alabama says my skin looks so
soft and clear I have seen a reduced
number of fine lines and dark spots I
have found a new lifetime product
absolutely love it geniusell was born
from its founder in a small New Jersey
town as a favor to one of his Pharmacy
customers using rare Botanical extracts
and scientifically researched
ingredients genucel is uniquely
formulated to Target all visible signs
of aging Fine Lines wrinkles dark spots
sagging jawline even the problem that I
struggle with as someone whose diet
consists of stogies and whiskey and
black coffee and no sleep which would be
under eye bags genu cell is terrific the
products work for both men and women
fellas I know we don't like to use
Cosmetics I'll just tell you
men use these products sometimes more
than women specifically Junior cell
because it's so great you aren't
guaranteed to see immediate results in
12 hours or your money back I love them
try geniusell's most popular package for
70 off at geniusell.com
join millions of happy customers who've
already fallen in love with the results
the founder is a great guy who believes
in really great stuff and makes a great
product for a limited time get
geniusell's probiotic extract infused
moisturizer free with every most popular
package subscribe to get a complimentary
bonus box go to genucel.com Knowles
these guys are bums they are bums and we
need to throw them out one of the
biggest bums in the government may be my
least favorite member of the Biden
Administration
certainly the glibest member of the
Biden Administration the most just
cloyingly liberal and saccharine and
yeah it just drives me crazy would be
Pete bootage Pete bootage who while
facing main many serious challenges from
his position as Transportation secretary
a major train derailment that poisoned
an entire Ohio town and threatened the
air and water supply for about 10 of the
country a guy who is seeing all sorts of
transportation problems from the
airlines to the roads to infrastructure
says that the thing he will most likely
be remembered for
the sun monster
climate is not nonsense dealing with
climate change is one of the biggest
things that people like me and people
like him will be remembered for after
we're gone
that is not true I was trying to think
well maybe that's true in the sense that
uh Pete bootage is spending all of his
time worried about the sun monster he's
not spending any of his time worried
about the railroads and the bridges and
the roads so that's why that's what
he'll be remembered for no I actually
believe Pete Buda judge will be one of
the only Transportation secretaries in
history to be remembered at all very few
people can name even One Transportation
secretary in history I remember Elaine
Chao had it during Trump's
Administration I I couldn't name you a
transportation secretary earlier than
that
but I think people will remember Pete
butterjudge because his tenure has been
so catastrophic there have been so many
Transportation catastrophes during Pete
bootage's reign
so why is he focused on climate change
when Buddha judge or any lib in
government says
well Hey listen would I well I hope that
I'm remembered for when my when my term
is up it's not not what I did the day by
day in my job it's what we did for
climate change
when when he says something like that
he's making a pseudo-religious claim
it is just the Bizarro World lib version
of when a Christian politician says
listen when all said and done once my
political Legacy is being written the
biographers are pulling out the notes I
hope they remember me as a good
Christian man a faithful servant of God
who did what he was called to do who
kept the faith who practiced virtue
we hear those kinds of statements all
the time
from Christians in public life
all the climate change piffle is the
same sort of statement for Libs in
public life because Libs generally
speaking don't believe in God they
either say outright that they don't
believe in God or they
maybe pay lip service to believe in God
but they certainly don't behave in any
way that would suggest that they do they
don't follow policies that would be in
accordance with God's Will and the
church and traditional religion and so
their religion is climate change that's
their eschatology that's their end times
prophecy that's their uh that's their
sanctification we'll be serving mother
Gaia and the climate that's their
atonement that's the the satisfaction
that is demanded for the sin of
pollution that's their that's their
roughly weird fake religious worldview
and so Pete Buddha judge says that it is
it is just the cherry on top of this
guy's confusion and incompetence Sunday
now with the
Biden Administration looking so weak
there are many many people who are
running for president I I have said it
before I think I might be the only
Republican in the country right now who
is not at least considering running for
president and it's only because I'm too
young the Constitution says I can't run
yet pretty much every other Republican
is considering a campaign
Republicans see blood in the water that
is why the race is on
we now have
three declared candidates on the right
Donald Trump is obviously running for
reelection Nikki Haley is running and
Vivek ramaswamy is running on the
Republican side Marianne Williamson who
is the new Agee left-wing candidate who
talked about dark psychic forces in 2020
she's running against Biden
the race is already on we have now seen
our first big Super PAC ad this ad would
seem to be supporting a candidate who
has not declared yet but who is
obviously going to run that would be
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis and Ron
DeSantis is Super PAC is taking aim at
Nikki Haley
A Tale of Two Governors Ron DeSantis
always putting Freedom First undoing the
Trump lockdowns taking on fauci's
vaccine passports taking on big
corporations and unions defending
parents rights taking on big Banks to
stop woke lending and taking a stand
sending Biden's migrants to Martha's
Vineyard DeSantis cut taxes banned
critical race Theory defended The Unborn
and expanded gun rights Ron DeSantis
always putting Freedom First Nikki Haley
awoke empty suit who looks good on TV
but that's about it Haley did nothing as
Governor but demolished Confederate
memorials then Haley quit on Trump at
the U.N to run for president on a
platform of identity politics and more
money for Ukraine two Governors two
different records Nikki Haley weak and
woke Rhonda santis always putting
Freedom First
so what does this tell you
for starters this ad did not come from
the DeSantis campaign because officially
speaking there is not right now an
official DeSantis campaign it's not like
it came from his Campaign Committee
however we have things in this country
called super Pacs we have outside
organizations that run ads on behalf of
candidates that's obviously what's
behind this ad
and it shows you that DeSantis is
obviously serious about running
why is he taking aim against Nikki Haley
Nikki Haley right now is much lower in
the polls than Ron DeSantis it shows you
that Ron DeSantis is aware of an
important fact in politics which is that
no matter how much of a long shot a
candidate would seem to be anything can
happen you want proof of that look no
further than 2016. all the smart people
said there's no way Donald Trump is ever
going to get the Republican nomination
and what happens he trounces everybody
else in the field
they said there's no way he could ever
be elected president the Hillary
campaign was hoping that Republicans
would nominate Trump they said Trump
would be the easiest one to be what
happens Trump absolutely cleans
Hillary's clock so DeSantis
and more to it team DeSantis is
signaling right now they are very very
serious about getting this nomination
they know they're in a good spot that
they have a real shot at clinching it
and they are not going to tolerate any
competition they're going to take every
competitor seriously you're taking Nikki
Haley very seriously though I think many
people are going to be looking at this
ad so early already airing in New
Hampshire and I think Iowa as well and
saying isn't this a little bit
aggressive
why is DeSantis who's the number two guy
with huge poll numbers right now going
so hard after another candidate it's
because Ron DeSantis intends to win the
race even if he's going to come off as a
little bit aggressive to do it the most
interesting line about that ad though
was not focused on Nikki Haley
everyone's just focusing on DeSantis
versus Haley in that ad the most
interesting line was
the first part says DeSantis put an end
to the Trump lockdowns
so it looks like it's an ad against
Nikki Haley but really the biggest dig
in there was a dig at Donald Trump who
is the only candidate beating Ron
DeSantis right now
this is pretty much the first time that
we have seen DeSantis or DeSantis world
really swing back at the steady and
increasing attacks from Donald Trump but
the candidate himself Rhonda Santos
himself when asked about it does not
want to go after the former president
so DeSantis was just asked on air hey
what's your reaction when when the
former president goes after you here's
his response
I read the whole thing not one
disparaging word about President Trump
are you guys speaking now do you plan on
speaking to him he seems to be taking
some shots at you
no I mean I mean I mean it's silly
season I mean you know how how some of
this stuff goes and obviously he he does
his thing and it's just that's kind of
kind of kind of who he is but what I
wanted to do was was just give an honest
appraisal of kind of how we got to this
point the failures of the D.C Republican
establishment and how Donald Trump was
speaking to things that some of the old
guard refused to address and and that's
just a fact and you know he can say you
know what he wants about me I'll always
give him credit for the things that he
did uh that were positive and I'm and
I'm appreciative of a lot of the things
uh that he did that mean I you know
agree with it with everything
um that he's doing lately or whatever uh
but ultimately it's about delivering for
the people you represent and delivering
for the country
this is the right tack
this is the right tack Ron DeSantis is
never going to beat Donald Trump in a
Barb throwing match it's not going to
happen Marco Rubio tried it do you
remember when Rubio went out and did
that whole routine about how Trump has
small hands and you know what that means
and it just didn't land Donald Trump is
one of the most famous successful
entertaining showmen in the entire
country
and DeSantis doesn't have to do it right
now Trump has a lot of incentive to
attack DeSantis
but DeSantis has a lot of momentum he's
got a lot of incentive not to irritate
Trump because DeSantis in order to win
needs to take over Trump's voters so
he's saying look I'm going to give Trump
a lot of credit for the things he did
that were positive he did some things
that were negative which we're going to
criticize in the Super PAC ads but I'm
going to take the high road I'm going to
be
and this is the whole pitch for the
DeSantis campaign I'm Trump without the
baggage
I'm trumpism without Trump
I'm the bigger better faster smarter
trumpism that's why he's running to the
right of trump right now
saying oh Trump was too weak on the
lockdowns I was really strong on the
lockdowns
that's going to be his pitch
so how is Trump going to counter that
I mentioned last week two weeks ago
after Trump went to Ohio
I said this is Peak Trump
this is the kind of trump that really
resonates the Trump that really
resonates is not the Trump throwing
insults at DeSantis
it's fine that's part of his character
but that's not what's going to win in
the nomination the Trump that resonates
is not the Trump complaining about the
stolen election in 2020. I am one of the
most sympathetic people to claims of
voter fraud and rigging and all the rest
of it in 2020. but it's it's just not
going to resonate with voters
in 2024
the most resonant Trump is the Trump who
shows up to Ohio and brings people water
and makes a joke about how some of the
water is not Trump water so you got to
watch out maybe don't don't drink it and
goes to McDonald's
and says you did a great job cooking
those Egg McMuffins I know this menu
better than anybody and he's passing out
hats and he's zinging one-liners he's
saying I'm forcing the federal
government to come here and he's hanging
out with people
to whom he uniquely appeals and with
whom he uniquely has something in common
it's paradoxical because he's a
billionaire from New York and yet he
really seems more than any other
Republican politician in my lifetime to
have something in common with the
Forgotten man the deplorables the
irredeemables the flyover country
the people that our Elites do not like
and so the way that Trump is now
pivoting I think he heard loud and clear
that that's what works focus more on
that but it's not just going to be talk
another one of the big pitches for Trump
is he's not one of these all talk no
action politicians
again I'm not assessing his presidency
I'm not assessing his Effectiveness in
this moment I'm just telling you that's
the pitch and so now what he's doing is
he's releasing policy
that leans into that identity and we
have not seen this in Trump's entire
political career we've seen this no
clearer than in the trade policy that
Trump released yesterday
Joe Biden claims to support American
manufacturing but in reality he's
pushing the same pro-china globalist
agenda that ripped the industrial heart
out of our country it ripped us apart
Biden and the globalist support raising
taxes on American production they
support more crippling regulations
Killing American jobs they support
skyrocketing domestic energy costs and
they support massive anti-American
multinational agreements that send our
wealth and factories overseas very
simply the Biden agenda taxes America to
build up China China is the big
beneficiary we cannot let that happen to
achieve this goal we will phase in a
system of universal Baseline tariffs on
most foreign products on top of this
higher tariffs will increase
incrementally depending on how much
individual foreign countries devalue
their currency we're not going to allow
bad things to happen to our country
anymore and we will eliminate Federal
contracts for any company that
outsources to China
you should watch the entire policy video
it's about five minutes long we don't
have time to play the whole thing on the
show
Trump is offering
an actual alternative
once again to all of the other
Republican candidates
Trump is calling explicitly for a
mercantilist trade policy
for the past 30 40 years
maybe even longer the Orthodoxy in the
GOP has been for free trade
the Freer the trade the better
Trump ran in many ways against that he
had problems with NAFTA
he was supportive of certain tariffs but
previously he said I support tariffs so
that we can get even Freer trade I
support tariffs as a negotiating
position maybe that's what he's doing
here now but he's taking a much stronger
stance on he's saying I support
Universal tariffs
I don't support free trade I support
mercantilism I support making Goods in
America encouraging people to buy
American Goods
strongly discouraging people from buying
foreign Goods strongly discouraging
companies from Outsourcing jobs overseas
even if it'll bring down the price of
products
what Donald Trump is proposing here
is
an end to globalism
free trade equals globalism
tariffs and mercantilism equals a focus
on the nation nationalism
now the problem you might say well good
I hate globalism so I'm with Trump
the risk to this kind of a bet
is that people like a lot of the fruits
of free trade
people like the fact that we can get
cheap consumer goods from China we don't
like that it strengthens China we don't
like that it gives China a major
national security advantage in some ways
over the United States we don't like to
be embarrassed by China to whom we are
so beholden that they get to fly a spy
balloon over our country and we look
completely weak we look like such
cowards we won't even shoot the thing
down
we don't we don't like that stuff but we
do like the cheap TVs we like the cheap
computers we like
we like that we get more disposable
income but we don't like that we lose
our jobs but we do like that we get a
raise when it comes to saving money on
products so it's a it's a more
complicated issue
then just okay now free trade used to be
good now free trade bad
but Trump is being quite clear here one
of the arguments about Trump back in
2016 was people said everyone only likes
his inflammatory rhetoric they're voting
for him for for personality not for
policy
I don't think that's true I'm with Ann
Coulter who wrote a whole book about
this before she decided not to like
Trump anymore but back in 2016 she wrote
a whole book about how no everyone's
getting that backwards people were
voting for Trump because he offered an
actual alternative on policy
in in many ways people voted for Trump
despite his personality but for his
policy because he was offering something
that is much more old school the free
traders in the audience are going to
hear this and they're going to say oh my
goodness this Trump he's not a real
conservative he doesn't support free
trade
the Republican party was founded on
tariffs that's that was one of the
founding issues for the Republican Party
back in the days of Abraham Lincoln
the Republican Party only became the
party of free trade in very recent
decades
protectionism tariffs that was the
conservative position
for a much longer time than free trade
has been the conservative position
if you don't want globalism this is how
to stop globalism some people like
globalism they think globalism reduces
the risk of war between nations maybe it
does but it comes with a lot of other
problems like you Outsource your
political power to International
institutions you lose your sovereignty
some cases you lose your way of life
there is a reaction and natural and I
think good political reaction against
the liberal globalism we've seen in
recent decades that's what brexit was
about that's what Trump 2016 was about
and Trump is staking his candidacy right
now on the belief that that reaction
against globalism has become only more
intense it has not abated at all
and it puts DeSantis in a tough spot
because what the Trump campaign is
seeing here I think is okay DeSantis is
going to try to run to the right of us
specifically on vaccines okay let's see
him run to the right of us on trade
and I don't know how DeSantis is going
to react to that
he's a very shrewd politician he's a
very capable governor
but but we see here some real strategy I
think or at the very least some real
skill from the Trump campaign you when
you're running a campaign you always
want to put your opponent in a difficult
if not impossible position that is what
they have done here on the issue of
trade
the free Traders are losing their minds
over this Paul Ryan was just interviewed
he's probably the most famous free
Trader Republican of the last 10 20
years
Paul Ryan was asked will he attend the
RNC next year
come 2024 the Republican National
Convention in Milwaukee where will you
be it uh it depends on who the nominee
is
I'll be here if it's somebody not named
Trump
you won't show up if it's not yeah I'm
not interested in participating in that
no even in Wisconsin
even Wisconsin
I won't show up if it's Trump that was
true of the previous republican nominees
for president in in 2016 the only living
former Republican nominee for president
who showed up to the RNC for Trump
was Bob Dole good old Bob do I love Bob
Dole first candidate I ever voted for
when I was six years old my mother let
me come into the voting booth she wanted
to vote for Clinton I begged her to vote
for Dole she let me pull the lever for
Dole
a young a young Republican even then and
why are the other Republicans so opposed
to Trump I get it Paul Ryan he's been
attacked by Trump he doesn't like
Trump's personality it goes deeper than
that a lot of the antipathy for Trump in
the Republican party is because he is
trying to take the party in a different
direction
and what what the Paul Ryan types are
arguing is that he's trying to take the
the Republican party in a in a heretical
direction not only unorthodox totally
heretical violating the sacred belief in
free trade
and sacred belief in Mass migration and
sacred belief in market capitalism Above
All Things is and it's not merely an
instrument but an end unto itself
and what Trump is saying is yeah I've
got I've got the actual conservative
position here and there are a lot of
people
who support that that's why
they couldn't now voters including
conservatives might not like that
alternative but at least we're getting
one and you're seeing this from DeSantis
too I don't want to say that Trump is
the only one leaning into this direction
the era of letting corporations do
whatever the hell they want
be it destroying our Traditions grooming
our kids upsetting our society all in
the name of making another one of the
almighty dollars that era is over Rhonda
Santa showed it yesterday when he signed
a law
depriving Disney woke Disney of its
previous
benefit it's government provided benefit
to govern its own territory
today
the corporate Kingdom finally comes to
an end
[Applause]
there's a new sheriff in town and
accountability will be the order of the
day
so what does this bill do
under this bill
under this bill Disney still gets some
perks under this bill Disney still has
exemptions from certain taxes on on
different construction materials on
impact fees for using public services it
still gets certain benefits that other
corporations also in Florida get though
Disney perhaps gets them to a larger
degree but under the new bill DeSantis
has authority to appoint every member of
this special tax District's five-member
governing body subject to approval by
the state senate so
until until now until very very recently
anyone
the Board of Supervisors here
has gotten to
appoint a chief executive to manage
day-to-day operations and this has been
selected basically by Disney now it will
be selected by DeSantis and additionally
anyone who has been employed by Disney
in the past three years will be barred
from serving on this board so it's it's
really really smart politics
because
DeSantis is getting a significant policy
win here but he's getting a huge
political win
the huge political win is Ron DeSantis
is sticking it to woke Disney DeSantis
didn't start this fight but he's going
to finish it Disney started the fight
when they attacked DeSantis for his
relatively modest bill on transiting the
kids
the the libs tried to call it don't say
gay the conservatives called it wait
till eight the bill said you can't trans
kids until they're in the fourth grade
in our schools really fairly modest Bill
the lib still went crazy about it so
they were lobbying hard against DeSantis
and DeSantis brought the hammer down as
absolutely he should have the squishes
said no don't wield the government
against DeSantis desanta said no it's
okay guys this is self-government this
is a republic
I have been elected by the people to
represent their interests Disney is
meddling in our state way too much
against the will of the people I'm going
to bring down the hammer
it's a major major political win and
it's a significant policy win but it's
pretty precise because he's still given
Disney a lot of nice stuff he's still
coming to the table here
that he's he's further defining himself
as
the very precise Trump
is the very clever Trump as the Trump is
a hammer right Trump is just this huge
sledgehammer DeSantis is oh he's getting
the win here but he's still leaving a
little bit for Disney and he's still
he's he's
furthering his campaign as
the really hyper sophisticated
disciplined Trump will that persuade
we'll find out Disney though is reeling
right now Disney executives are now
reflecting on why people don't like
their movies anymore specifically this
movie light year remember light year
came out it was the new Toy Story movie
it completely flopped and it was a movie
that had a lesbian kiss in it and where
they replaced Tim Allen one of the only
conservative actors in Hollywood they
replaced his voice and had some other
guy some lib Guy voice Buzz Lightyear so
here's what Disney said
said we've done a lot of soul searching
about that because we all love the movie
we love the characters in the premise I
think probably what We've Ended on in
terms of what went wrong is that we
asked too much of the audience
that was Pixar's Chief creative officer
when they hear Buzz they're like great
where's Mr Potato Head and Woody and Rex
and then we drop them into this science
fiction film that they're like what
even if they've read the material on the
press it was just a little too distant
both in concept and I think in the way
that characters were drawn that they
were portrayed it was much more of a
science fiction
yeah maybe I don't know I think the
concept was pretty easy the concept was
Buzz Lightyear as a toy
and Buzz Lightyear is based on a movie
character so this is the movie
okay yeah maybe that won't be quite as
popular as Toy Story one of the most
popular
cartoon franchises of all time
but I get it that's fine I don't think I
don't think the audience is so stupid
that they couldn't get that concept
sci-fi is a very popular genre I don't
think it's that the audience just can't
get into sci-fi no it was the wokeness
guys it was the lesbian kiss and it was
the replacing the voice now some people
said well they had to replace the voice
because it's a different kind of
character
it's Buzz Lightyear the movie character
not Buzz Lightyear the toy
yeah it's a little too clever by half if
you ask me
because toys are just they just play
recordings of the movie characters
so if the joke is that the quality of
the toy is so low that the voice is
totally different it just doesn't play I
think they probably leaned into booting
Tim Allen because he's a conservative
and I think that the movie flopped
because it was woke and in the press it
was being portrayed correctly as woke
and then the audience didn't show up
it's not that complicated guys we talked
yesterday about the El Salvadoran
president
who had that wonderful video and this
incredible policy
where he's he's cut his murder rate by
58 in El Salvador by just locking up all
the criminals turns out it's really
simple you want to you want to cut the
murder rate lock up the murderers
it's really simple you want audiences to
go show up to your movies don't make
them these woke tedious lectures
give the audience what they want they're
going to show up to your movie speaking
of groomers like Disney Randy Weingarten
head of the teacher Union
is out doing what she does best which is
whining and screaming and trying to get
more money and power this time at the
Supreme Court because there is a
challenge to the Biden administration's
ability to to forgive student loans with
the stroke of a pen take a listen
and this is what really pisses me off
during the pandemic we understood that
small businesses were hurting and we
helped them and it didn't go to the
Supreme Court to challenge it fake
businesses were hurting and we helped
them and it didn't go to the Supreme
Court to challenge it all of a sudden
when it's about our students they
challenge it the corporations challenge
it the student loan lenders challenge
that that is not right that is not fair
and that is what we are finding as well
when we say has also to death that was
Randy Weingarten doing her Howard Dean
impression we're gonna get
not not very persuasive
and the rhetorical device she uses is
not very persuasive because what does
she say she says when it's about
forgiving money to businesses that's
fine
but when it's about our students
find garden
the woman who wouldn't let our students
back into school for two years even
though they faced statistically pretty
much zero risk from the coronavirus but
I didn't want to do it because I
insisted that my union members get more
time off and get paid for it hi Randy
winegarden who care about our students I
want to make sure they get their student
loans forgiven
Randy Weingarten students
of which he has none she doesn't teach
any she doesn't actually have any
students she's a union boss
Randy weingarten's students though the
students that her members are teaching
don't have any student loans
they're public school students they're
high school students
middle school students Elementary School
students they don't have student loans
what is Randy Weingarten talking about
she's not at the Supreme Court
representing students
she's at the Supreme Court representing
her members
the teacher union members they're the
ones with the student loans
the student debt crisis rally in D.C
is to stop a court challenge to Biden
canceling ten thousand dollars in
federal student loans for individuals
making less than 125 thousand dollars
per year or households earning less than
two hundred fifty thousand dollars per
year
annually as of 2020 and 2021
that describes the teacher union members
as always
the teacher Union is not about the
students
the teacher Union harms students
on pretty much every single front
the teacher Union exists not to help
students but to oppose students and to
support
the teacher union members they're the
ones that they're there for
we're going to support our students by
locking them out of school and saddling
them with even more debt
whoa not persuasive you know
one of the great things about Jordan
Peterson is he dispenses his wisdom with
tough love in equal measure and you will
find plenty of both those things in this
new five-part series out on daily wire
plus called vision and Destiny the
series is designed to help you find
Clarity and direction this is badly
needed a lot of people have no idea who
they are especially when it comes to sex
and gender here's a clip from vision and
Destiny explaining Jordan's View
what is gender well it's what people
feel they are it's like yeah that's your
theory eh that's a stupid theory if
there's it's not going anywhere that
theory and so that's that's just a
theory that enables you to claim
something like the Primacy of your
narcissistic whim it has nothing to do
with
the careful delineation of what actually
constitutes identity and so it's complex
because there are there is variability
in masculinity and femininity
on top of the binary biological
substructure and so that also means that
you have to have a certain amount of
tolerance for role variability and you
should
because there are masculine women and
there are feminine men and it's harder
for them in some real sense to adopt the
rule that would be easily commensurate
with their biological identity because
they share many features
temperamental features that are
characteristic of the opposite sex but
that doesn't mean that they're born in
the wrong body
the first two episodes are out right now
new episodes are releasing every week
but it's all exclusive for daily wire
Plus members while the rest of you Hoy
polloi out there who won't Fork over
your money you don't get
Dr Jordan Peterson's very interesting
views on gender and sex and lobsters and
all the rest of it so head on over that
I got to work on my it's not quite there
yet it's close it's not quite there yet
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
to watch vision and Destiny
speaking of schools
New York city mayor Eric Adams
said something really true
I
something wrong did I hold on Am I
Dreaming am I did I
uh I'm gonna pinch myself to oh mayor
Eric Adams in New York said something
really true and important that we should
all learn from
something's going on in our cities
Chicago threw out Lori Lightfoot The New
York city mayor is saying something true
and smart
Eric Adams
described how our schools specifically
schools in New York City have plummeted
to such depths of degradation
we would not have homeless in this city
we would not have a crisis of domestic
violence
we would not have children because when
we took prayers out of schools guns came
into schools
when we took prayer out of schools guns
came into schools
fact check true
yeah that's right
he's he's not giving an historical study
here
he's making a philosophical and
anthropological point this is how human
beings work
when you stop them from worshiping God
it's not even just that you don't
encourage it anymore you're not allowed
to have prayer in schools now so when
you discourage them from worshiping God
and turning their eyes up to good things
and to virtue
into truth
they're going to turn it somewhere else
they're going to turn their attention to
bad things they're going to turn their
attention to false Idols they're going
to turn their attention to falsehoods
and and vice
that is what's going to happen because
we live in time and space we're human
beings we got to do something there's no
neutrality there's no push pause
you take prayers out of schools that's
when the guns are going to come into
schools or when the pornography is going
to come into schools or when whatever is
going to come into schools
Democrats love that we took prayer out
of schools
they love that we took the Bible out of
schools and yet here even New York city
mayor Eric Adams
what he just said it would be
indistinguishable from what some right
winger down in Texas politician would
have said some Christian
fundamentalist Theocratic it's the same
thing that Eric Adams just said Eric
Adams just said we need prayer in
schools
obviously we do
if you had said 10 years ago if you had
said we need prayer in schools you would
have been considered a fringe right-wing
Republican
but but this is where we're seeing a
little bit of Hope
Chicago throws that Lori Lightfoot mayor
Adams says things that are interesting
you're seeing a little some Rays of Hope
here creeping in which is that people
are beginning to realize oh maybe that
was a mistake
maybe when you create a national policy
turning your country away from God maybe
that's not going to work out so great
and it has not worked out sure it's
really simple stuff and I'm turning my
attention back to
the El Salvador president actually after
we did the segment on him yesterday I
noticed that President bouquet in El
Salvador tweeted out the bit from this
show and and quoted the segment
and
then I went to the president's Twitter
page I said oh that's kind of cool he
tweeted out the segment and then I saw
he had another video and this is kind of
the answer to the propaganda video of
the MS-13 gangsters that he put out you
know president bouquet has arrested
thousands and thousands of these
gangsters I think there's 65 000 of them
now locked up these guys look like demon
bugs they've got weird green face
tattoos and he's humiliating them and
he's sent the Army out to deal with the
crime problem
and reduce the murder rate by 58 well
now here's the other side of that not
just the Doom and Gloom and fire and
brimstone we're gonna get you bad guys
here's
the hopeful message for the rest of the
country I will translate by reading the
text on the screen because my Spanish is
no good
president bouquet standing out
talking to his troops in a field for
eight months we've been fighting this
war against the gangs and thank God
we're winning
this is a very surprising victory that
is nearly within our grass let it be
clear that the glory is for God and it
is God's glory
we humans are lucky
to be instruments of God
to bring peace Liberty and happiness if
to the Salvadoran people
these values were probably not strong in
this land and were stronger in other
languages and that's why those lands
grew and became great that they are
losing those values
and on the other hand the values that
previously were degraded in our country
are now the most important ones just
take a look at yourself young men and
women
How could a nation not rise up with
values such as these How could a nation
not rise up when it puts God first and
then puts in the hard work and effort
with these kinds of values
beautiful
political science students will be
studying this speech history students
will be studying this speech years from
now
this is beautiful
and true
the president of El Salvador
sounds like an American founding father
in that speech
more so he sounds like
Governor Bradford Governor Winthrop were
some of the very earliest Americans who
helped to build our country
they kept it very simple
it's just like the policy what's the
policy you want to fight crime lock up
the criminals
you want to build a great nation put God
first everything else will follow seek
ye first the kingdom of heaven all the
other Goods will follow after that
president bukele he says
in our country these values had been
degraded other nations had those values
that's why those other nations became
great and now those other nations are
turning away from those values who's he
talking about he's talking about us
and he's showing you something beautiful
that happens throughout history
and that you see
certainly in the history of Salvation
certainly you see this throughout the
Bible
that
very often it can be small Mighty groups
small Underdog groups
who put on the armor of God
who can astound
and frankly embarrass
the supposedly far greater Nations
which have profited profited from God's
grace and then turned their backs on him
go on done something else doesn't turn
out well for those countries doesn't
turn out well for those Empires
he says that line
How could a nation with these values not
rise up not become great
and not it's very very simple I'm not
saying that it's easy but it's simple
president buchelli's speech here
could have been given
not just by the founding fathers or the
early Colonial Americans could have been
given by any great leader in our
civilization going back to Antiquity all
the way up until about 20 years ago
now we don't hear these speeches very
often
but it's pretty simple stuff folks
these big political problems
that our opponents want to pretend are
so complicated oh well you know gender
and sex it's so it's not complicated men
or men and women are women well you know
the issue of reproductive freedom and no
it's not don't kill babies it's really
simple well the issue of immigration is
so complicated Ronald Reagan said
illegal immigration is not complicated
it's illegal stop it
crime is not complicated lock up the
criminals build more prisons lock them
up punish them harder you'll get less
crime
how do we have a great country look
toward God look to the source and Summit
of goodness himself being himself you'll
have a good country you look away from
God you're going to have a bad country
it's very very simple
we have got the rest of the show coming
up now
we've got
some Tick Tock haters according to my
producer he tells me we've got some Tick
Tock haters I have got to being a real
cool hip Tick Tock influencer myself
I've got to react
in real time to these haters so the rest
of the show continues now you don't want
to miss it become a member use code
Knowles kwels a check out for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you